if you like searching netflix for
something new to watch you've probably
found a very innovative often shocking
program from south korea squid game has
hit number one in 94 countries including
the u.s it's part of an effort by
netflix to gather programming from all
over the world and present it in local
languages carter evans shows us how new
technology and much more attention to
detail can turn sound dubbing into an
art
a player who refuses to play will be
eliminated
the korean drama squid game follows
hundreds of people deeply in debt who
play a series of children's games
competing for cash
green lights you either win or die
trying
netflix says more than
142 million households around the world
streamed the show in its first month
and that giant doll that terrorized
players on screen is a pop culture
sensation from mexico to moscow the
squid game phenomenon is everywhere did
you hear that
korean american greg chun is the english
voice of the main character song hoon
according to netflix casting actors of
asian descent for the dubbing was a
deliberate choice that's our job and
there is to make every moment as
believable as possible and try to convey
as much of the original intent
emotionally and dramatically that we can
god
okay you're nothing but a skinny old
woman so i'll let you win
but this is what might come to mind when
you think of dubbed foreign movies but i
must find out the truth yes of course
kung fu films from the 70s and their
laughable lip syncs somehow we must get
him
at any cost well that means you were
given the number one
now netflix is working to change that
perception
a person died
that man there just died
by recrafting the dubbing process it's
so much more
work than people realize
in an la recording studio squid game
dubbing director madeleine heil showed
us how it's done uh we need to be up by
the end of the word not the end of the
punctuation okay it's so difficult to
try to preserve all the nuances when you
just don't have a lot of time or they're
not enough lip flaps but still fitting
it by fitting it in yeah
hello cards
the original script is translated then
the actor and director work together to
ensure the dialogue fits the movement of
the mouth on screen you really expect us
to buy that in korean the way the
language is structured there are all
these sort of pauses that wouldn't exist
in english if we were expressing the
same sentiment it's more like you just
finished running breathing you want
people to get sucked in and not to be
rattled out of it by like oh that looked
weird oh he's breathing with his mouth
open but his mouth is closed ah your
mother and i were talking the other day
she told me you were out of the country
on a business trip eventually like
getting to the point where you know
you're two episodes in and you're not
even paying attention to the fact that
they're speaking english and they were
originally speaking korean you're in
grave danger follow me quick
since 2019 american viewership of korean
dramas including the king's affection
has increased more than 200 percent
you're early i told you
i've changed
and the attention to detail during
dubbing is turning other non-english
netflix shows into hits like francis
lupin and spain's money heist but now
all of you are here as our hostages
the process is a little like karaoke
chun reads the translation as it scrolls
across the screen did you hear that
we've got our screen here greg invited
me to give it a shot how hard can it be
the words are going to go by as it goes
along you want to kind of hack keep one
eye on that keep one eye on the picture
and the mouth if you're moving if you're
standing up if you're turning this way
it affects the way your speech comes out
it's subtle but it's if it's not done
it's noticeable i would imagine that
facial expressions they impact the way
that your voice sounds oh absolutely
yeah hey did you hear that
a person died
that man in there just died you're
pitching up a little bit because you're
trying to sound like him his voice is
you god he's you big big my man big yeah
yeah
wow it's out of my comfort zone because
i felt very big for me could someone do
something
i won't be getting a call back this is a
lot harder than it looks dubbing has
evolved into a form of art you have to
respect the writing as well as the
on-camera actor's performance it's a big
balancing act voiceover actors have to
be really humble because you're not
originating a performance you are
honoring someone else's performance but
it's those kind of people who are
willing to go okay
i don't get to make
the big choices i have to color in what
the original actor has left for me to
flesh out follow me quick
greg chun has brought more than 200
characters to life from barbie's dad
remember i made that ancient artifacts
documentary a while back
dad you're being weird to the scientist
who resurrects dinosaurs that
ankylosaurus has only been incubating
for 10 weeks but he daydreams about
meeting the real star of squid game i
would love to meet him i would freak out
if i met jj lee man i mean to say it's
an honor to be his voice for this show
is an understatement someday maybe
green light
and with promises of a season two on the
horizon that day may come
for cbs mornings i'm carter evans in
hollywood
i think that looks fun that was really i
mean first of all i'd never watch movies
with overdubs because of my experience
as a kid growing up watching those great
shaw brothers movies from hong kong it
just scarred me so i want to hear the
original language and i read the
subtitles but when you see the amount of
work that it takes to get it right now
make it not look cheesy
i grew up on foreign films and let me
say carter evans yes you did a great
job it is harder than it looks like well
done
i think nate could do well at that too
it doesn't kind of i'm not i now feel
i'm missing something nothing you gotta
watch squid game i do i got to watch it
i gotta put all my big girl panties and
do it do it do it you figure of what
panties panties glad panties